hey guys it's dennis the founder take
care and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our discussion about this rumor
that's really patrol well because you
know true detective has ended the first
season and we know it's an anthology
mini series of the thing there and
restart it with new characters new
storyline new actors and everything same
writer and so now that it's over yep
rumors have been coming out and the
latest rumor which is not being reported
by any of the big ones like rising rumor
rumor petroleum a rumor yeah which is
brad pitt is in talks to star in right
true detective next season brad pitt
like Matthew McConaughey has gotten
better with age Brad Pitt definitely
obviously the movie star more than
McConaughey in the sense of he just he's
Brad Pitt I mean it's just he's Brad
Pitt that's who you know come on uh but
I like Brad Pitt a lot he's a great
actor he's hydrated he's under varying
under way because people look at him
then like 08 brad pitt angelina a cheat
on Jennifer Aniston broke her heart you
know friends he knows all that stuff
like all that drama gets in the way of
Brad Pitt how good of an actor he is so
I would love to see him in the next
season of True detective yeah I mean
movies like assassination of jesse james
12 monkeys a bunch of other movies even
producing like 12 years a slave those
his producing nominated for a few Oscars
for Moneyball so I think he would be a
great fit of course you know I think
people think of like seven because he
was a you know sort of the detective
things XO you get him in there but since
they talked about having a female lead
as well this is about hard women Sally
for the writer phrase did so you would
think that there'd be at least a female
part writer who would you want to see is
that female partner ooh well if they're
gonna stick with the whole movie getting
people from the film and I think so like
probably like a Jessica Chastain the
other contestants great she's busy she's
like girls work and she would be great
though oh man Kate Winslet winslet would
be good hit by a chat k plan shed all
the Cates maybe my vital throw the pita
in there I mean she's getting word now
no she's probably at Star Wars um I
don't know there's there's uh that's a
good question
on top of my head you know I don't know
that that's tough but I want to see I
really want this next season to feature
more women because this was I mean I'm
not trying to pull these cards out race
and all that I mean this true detective
was the classic white man middle-aged
point of view problem and that's fine
there's nothing wrong with hey there's
this great Jason maybe not every show
can be the wire not every show is going
to be the wire and featured that diverse
of a cast but I would like to see at
least some females point of view in this
next so i am looking forward to seeing
the female ass that side of the show for
sure and in to further elaborate on this
rumor brad pitt the rumor is saying that
he's in negotiations or he's talking
about it but he he wants to do it but
they're trying to see if it fits into
his schedule because this is the
commitment World War Z sequel you know
maybe I don't know he's busy yeah but
luckily because of the of how true
detective is shot I guess it's you know
they're doing only eight episodes which
is about like three four movies worth
mmm however they have a compacted
schedule so it might equal maybe two
movies worth i don't know the exact
shooting schedule can someone like a
brad pitt can afford that much time if
he doesn't get it who are some guys you
would like to see in there oh I think
alike a Joseph gordon-levitt buddy i was
thinkin to the guy always i'm horrible
names up from moon Oh Sam Rockwell Sam
Rockwell I like that well he was great
uh you know people are talking about
maybe to atone as your fool that's
really actually would be good no Idris
Elba look at the bros yeah hey just yeah
wire the wire cutter Casey Affleck yeah
I like yeah Casey yeah he's good in the
Indian and broke world yeah he's really
good yeah yeah so like maybe pairing one
of them went with with a female lead
like we were talking about Jessica
Chastain or something i think that would
draw a lot of people in and this is
definitely something that the actors
would be doing not so much for the money
no cuz they can make him away more money
doing a big movie do a big movie this
was be because kind of more the prestige
of it and that they want to do it I see
like oh man look at Matthew McConaughey
and woody harrelson there kicking I want
an Emmy yeah well I'm Plus everyone
everyone's talking about true gatech
right right at least on the I would say
not so much on the mainstream level but
on the the yeah on the more
knowledgeable level there are really
good numbers yeah look at oh yeah hey
any other suggestions or thoughts no
that's all I'm just excited to see
location I mean we're thinking LA with
the whole transportation system rumors
and the the cults behind that so
hopefully la I wouldn't mind seemed like
an LA noire vibe you know I mean do it
right I like gangster squad or something
like that doesn't leave a Carville so
I'm excited I hope they kind of hope
they do it in LA alright cool alright
guys so let us know what you think of
this rumor I mean obviously it's to be
taken with a grain of salt draws it's
not we're being reported by and the big
guys do you think it's true do you think
Brad Pitt would be a good fit who would
you want to see would you want to see
some of the names that we mentioned for
the male or female do you want to see
two females as a leader you want to get
mail or feet and female parent you can
let us know in the comments section
below and think here calm or on our
YouTube channel think hero pro make sure
to subscribe to that those are can find
us on Twitter hunk adenosine myself I
let's know about some of your favorite
cop drama shows wire broadchurch over
there in England let us know what you
think about the upcoming season of true
detective season 2 and you can find us
at think hero i'm at griffin de and we
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure to LIKE that page and share our
videos on Twitter and other social media
you